A large percentage of what people will
contribute to something is sometimes
it's as much a donation in support of a
relationship as it is a donation in
support of a cause.
What we wanted to be sure to do was make
sure that for the motivated person who's
got a target and a goal that that what
we were engineering was an incredible
toolbox for them to use all of our best
ideas that we've ever had and even to
source from other people by surfing
around in the site,
effective ways of taking their
motivation and their energy and you
know,
leveraging it into really good
productivity in terms of their personal
fundraising.
So on the one hand you want to supply
the motivated person with everything
they need to do a really good job.
The next ring out is people who might
not have a specific connection.
So for organizations,
we think one of the things that's really
potent is the idea of in some ways doing
what Obama did,
which is take people who are already
donors to you and turn them into small
fundraisers for you.
You know,
I mean,
if a person is capable of giving 50
bucks themselves,
but it's really easy for them to reach
out to their family and friends and just
on the strength of personal
relationships,
say,
could I get,
um,
you know,
10 more people to donate 50 bucks,
then they've just multiplied their own
capacity by 10 times.
Anyone who was involved in fundraising
will tell you that that kind of
multiplying effect,
it has huge ramifications.